goiânia quadro eu falar sobre a
tecnologia no campo para maior
produtividade
primeiro vou falar sobre a origem das
plantas aqui vocês podem ver que as
pessoas começaram a ser cultivadas em
vários lugares
daí na época do descobrimento em 20 as
caravelas e vieram da europa para o
brasil para a américa do norte e américa
central e de lá trouxeram todos esses
alimentos que estão aqui para europa e
de lá e exportar para o mundo todo
mas essa zona urbana 2 59 bilhões de
pessoas mundo ea gente eu só vou
continuar sendo o mesmo que agora vamos
ter também que nem vai aumentar o
tamanho de pessoas
então a gente tem que continuar
preservando ele ou preservá lo então daí
teremos essa quantidade só em termos de
angola
agora eu falo forte para mais para dar
alimentos para mais pessoas porque as
coisas como aqui eles podem ver pelas
costas no trecho do solo como enxofre
magnésio cálcio potássio fósforo
nitrogênio fazer fotos e cuida do sol e
com água drogas ou seja fungos e insetos
assim os fungos comendo das plantas e
aqui os insetos com meninas
então pra ele devido a isso o agrônomo
mergulhou dieta especial de fertilizante
ou de agrotóxico para as plantas para
jogar mas que você espera eliminar essas
placas pragas e que o sol continue forte
agora vou falar sobre três tecnologias
a primeira é assim assim você me
atrapalha você tira em vez de você tirar
a palha você deixa ela lá cortada que
serve como escudo por solo que é ajuda a
assim quando exigiu agrotóxico é é a
palha defende o sol roxo ou quando a
chuva cair a palha defende um pouco só
também a segunda
mais gosta é assim primeiro se planta a
soja grande planta algodão que tira jogo
só depois implicações que daí a pessoa
depois empatar a pastagem
depois de fazer bastante pedindo a jesus
e depois plantar soja de novo que dá
energia pessoa e se você continuar
fazendo isso é você vai poder pensar
diversas coisas e o solo continua forte
o terceiro assim é como se fosse uma
cadeia limitá lo por não comer a folha
daí a junya koga em fuga daí se a gente
jogar muitos utilizam ante outro tóxico
no solo
a joaninha a joaninha vai morrer vai
ficar um número baixo daí o fogão vai
montar número um número muito alto
daí a sua atenção você não vai ter como
controlar a sua plantação e daí é e você
também vai prejudicar o solo jogando
fertilizante então assim deixa ver como
o fogão já um pouco disso utilizam ante
o retoque ficou no solo para evitar isso
e daí pra você matar algumas linhas
porque daí as linhas também como a folha
tentou se matar janinha porque dela como
fúria daí você mata ela e então você
mata sair mas não mata muito porque a
urna com um empurrão também e que daí um
pouco também como foi então assim você
continua com seu divórcio em solo também
estudar uma agricultura sustentável
então quem tem que continuar preservando
solo porque para que no futuro como a
quantidade de pessoas são continue forte
e temos alimentos em tempo e temos como
dar alimento para todas elas
obrigada